creo que en el vídeo pasado quedó mucho
más claro la idea de que eran vectores
linealmente dependientes y linealmente
independientes y en este vídeo lo que
quiero ver es una forma un poco más
matemática un poco más abstracta o algo
un poco más formal una definición más
formal de lo que es linealmente
dependiente y bueno por ende también lo
que es linealmente independiente por lo
tanto me voy a tomar un conjunto de
vectores me voy a tomar los vectores b1
b2 b3 esta bn este es un conjunto de
vectores y bueno yo voy a decir que este
conjunto es linealmente dependiente de
pendiente si y sólo si pasa lo siguiente
y ojo si sólo si es un operador
matemático muy importante hay veces que
se puede común si con una y demás ya
veis que describe como una vía
condicional que es esta flecha doble
este conjunto de vectores es linealmente
dependiente si y sólo si si pasa los
siguientes hice uno por ver uno más dos
por verdad más todos los demás más cn
por de n es igual al vector
toda esta suma es igual al vector 0 al
vector 0 por lo tanto voy a poner un 0
remarcado o en su dado caso el vector 0
es aquel vector que tiene todas sus
entradas ceros y bueno como no sé en qué
dimensiones estamos voy a poner un
vector con muchos ceros porque al final
estoy hablando en forma muy general no
estamos tomando unos vectores solamente
en r2 r3 estamos tomando los vectores en
cualquier dimensión y bueno si pasa esto
entonces va a pasar esta combinación
lineal o en todo caso al revés si pasa
esta combinación lineal que nos dé el
vector 0 entonces vamos a obtener que
estos vectores son linealmente
dependientes y ojo esto es válido si
algunas 6 no son 0 es decir que si
existe al menos una y alguna constante
de todas estas constantes que tengo aquí
que no es cero se cumple esto
esto quiere decir que al menos una de
estas constantes al menos una con una
que no sea cero y se cumpla esto
entonces va a pasar el sí y sólo sí es
linealmente dependiente si pasa que esta
combinación lineal es igual a cero al
vector cero y viceversa y fíjate la
importancia de que al menos 16 sea
distinta de 0 porque si todas fueran 0
pues multiplicar las por un vector
me daría claramente el vector 0 y bueno
en el vídeo pasado yo les había dicho
que un conjunto de vectores eran
linealmente dependiente si al menos un
vector lo podíamos ver como combinación
lineal de los demás se acuerdan de que
escribirlo de esta manera vamos a
ponerle un poco más matemático y yo les
dije en el vídeo pasado que si yo tenía
un vector no sé vamos a suponer que es
el vector b 1 vamos a tomarnos el vector
de 1 recuerda que al final puede ser
cualquier vector entonces suponiendo que
el vector de uno es aquel que era
linealmente dependiente de todos los
demás es decir que se veía de las formas
vamos a cambiar de constantes
a 1 por b 2 no dejes no poner esto mejor
a 2 x b 2 + a 3 x b tres más todos los
demás hasta n por b n es decir veíamos
que un vector era linealmente
dependiente si existía una combinación
lineal de todos estos vectores que
precisamente nos daban este vector esto
es lo que habíamos visto en el vídeo
pasado se acuerdan bueno déjenme ver si
realmente esta definición es congruente
con lo que acabamos de decir es decir es
congruente con este sí solos y si yo
encuentro una combinación lineal de
todos estos vectores que sea igual a
cero y que alguna de estas constantes
sea distinta de cero entonces ya cabe y
bueno lo primero que voy a hacer es
pasar a b1 del otro lado lo voy a pasar
con signo negativo entonces me queda el
vector 0 es igual a menos uno por b uno
más a dos por b dos más a tres por
detrás es más más n por b n y luego lo
que hice fue pasar al vector de uno del
otro lado con signo contrario o dicho de
otra manera x menos uno pero fíjate qué
bonito porque ya encontramos que
v 1 al menos este vector está
multiplicado por una constante que no es
cero porque la constante que está
multiplicando a uno es este menos uno
por lo tanto fíjate la definición que
tengo aquí a la derecha tengo que
encontrar una combinación lineal de
todos estos vectores que me dé el vector
cero y que al menos uno con una de estas
constantes que está multiplicando estos
vectores sea distinta de cero por lo
tanto es linealmente dependiente que
crees encontré una que es distinta de
cero cual menos uno menos uno está
multiplicando a b1 y nos da el vector
cero por lo tanto estamos dándonos
cuenta que si en efecto la forma en la
que veíamos linealmente dependiente en
el vídeo pasado es congruente con esto
que le estoy diciendo y bueno ahora qué
va a pasar al revés si yo tengo este de
aquí y quiero llegar a lo que vimos en
el vídeo pasado a que uno de los
vectores se puede escribir como
combinación de los demás y ojo estoy
suponiendo que al menos una de estas
constantes es distinta de cero por lo
tanto sin pérdida de generalidad voy a
tomarme que la primer constante es
distinta en 0 es decir vamos a suponer
que ese 1 es distinto
y bueno a continuación hacer es dividir
todo en 13 1 y como sea uno es distinto
de 0 no pasa nada y si puedo encontrar
esta división entonces me queda b1 c2 en
13 1 por b 2 + + todos estos más se n en
13 1 es igual a 0
y bueno si ya dividí todo en 13 1 lo que
voy a hacer a continuación es pasar el
b1 del otro lado de esta igualdad lo voy
a pasar con signo contrario estos me
quedase 2 en 13 1 por b 2 + + todos
estos más en en 13 1 por b n
aquí no faltó el bn aquí arriba está
olvidando tvn y bueno esto va a ser
igual a menos de 1 porque estoy pasando
al vector de uno del otro lado y bueno
si yo lo que quiero es que este vector
sea positivo entonces voy a multiplicar
todo por menos y me queda menos de 2 en
13 1 por b 2 - - - - - - en el 13 1 por
ben es igual a b uno positivo y que
creen ya encontré una combinación lineal
de estos vectores que me da el otro
vector es decir de b2 b3 de 4 hasta bn
que me dan el vector b
que era justo lo que veíamos en el vídeo
pasado por lo tanto esto quiere decir
que también es congruente con lo que
vimos en el vídeo pasado entonces vamos
a ver algunos ejemplos de todo esto que
acabamos de ver sobre todo de esta forma
de encontrar una combinación lineal de
todos los vectores con alguna de estas
seis que sea distinta de cero que sea
igual al vector cero para probar si el
conjunto de vectores es linealmente
independiente o en su dado caso
linealmente dependiente vamos a ver si
encontramos todas estas constantes y
alguna que no sea cero entonces vamos a
tomarnos el siguiente ejemplo me voy a
tomar el conjunto de vectores el
conjunto de vectores 2 1 y después voy a
tomar el siguiente vector el vector 3 2
y bueno este conjunto de vectores que es
de 2 vectores quiero saber si es
literalmente dependiente o linealmente
independiente y pues bueno para resolver
esta pregunta vamos a utilizar lo que ya
aprendimos lo que acabamos de ver vamos
a tomarnos una combinación lineal de
estos dos vectores ya esto vamos a
igualarlo al vector 0 y esto es para
fijarnos en qué es lo que va a pasar con
las constantes por lo tanto tengo que
ese 1
el vector 2 1 c 2 por el vector 3 2
tiene que ser igual a 0 y bueno esto es
para ver si son linealmente
independientes o linealmente
independientes y bueno vamos a ver cuál
es cada caso si yo tuviera que ese uno o
dos es distinto de cero es decir no es
cero entonces va implicar que es un
sistema dependiente recuerdas justo esta
fue la definición que vimos ahí arriba y
c1 c2 era distinto de cero entonces el
sistema de pendiente y date cuenta que
este es el otro caso si c1 c2 no es cero
pues el otro caso no queda que ese 1 y c
2 ambos sean igual a 0 entonces me queda
que es un sistema independiente y bueno
cómo voy a saber esto pues lo que quiero
que veas es que aquí tengo una constante
que multiplica un vector más otra
constante que multiplica otro vector
igualados al vector cero esto quiere
decir que puedo igualar al componente
por componente la componente x de la
suma de los vectores igualdad el
componente x del vector 0 y la
componente y también 2
s 13 veces 2 es el vector 0 recuerda que
es el vector cuyas entradas son cero y
cero por lo tanto no quedaría dos veces
es 13 veces 2
esto tiene que ser igual a cero esto es
lo que debe de pasar para que se cumpla
el primer componente y en la segunda
componente me queda que una vez se 1 es
decir se uno más dos veces dos tiene que
ser igual también a cero y ya con esto
llevó a un sistema de ecuaciones de los
que ya conocemos en álgebra es un
sistema de ecuaciones de dos por dos muy
sencillo de realizar y esto lo podemos
resolver utilizando nuestro conocimiento
de álgebra por lo tanto lo que voy a
hacer multiplicar a la ecuación 1 por un
medio en 9 que dar c 1 + 3 medios desde
2 estoy dividiendo toda esta ecuación
entre 2 es igual a cero entre 2 que es
cero ya continuación que voy a hacer es
restar la ecuación 2 a esta ecuación de
verde me va a quedarse 11 se cancelan
dos veces dos menos tres medios de ese 2
esto es lo mismo que un medio de ese 2 y
0 -0 me queda 0 y de aquí obtengo que
ese 2 es igual a cero yo obtuve que la
primer constante es igual a cero cuánto
vale ese uno bueno si yo pongo aquí pero
eso se canse
y esto se va a cero y me queda que ese
10 es igual a 0 y de aquí obtengo que se
1 también en 0 y qué creés ya encontré
mi valor de mis dos constantes y este
valor es único cuando se 2 y c1 es igual
a 0 se cumple este sistema de ecuaciones
y por lo tanto se cumple esta igualdad y
entonces esto qué significa que existe
uno y c2
ambas son cero es que mi sistema tiene
solamente vectores linealmente
independientes y bueno recuerda que si
tenemos un conjunto con vectores
linealmente independientes entonces cuál
era el espacio vectorial tiene grado por
dos vectores que son linealmente
independientes pues claro el espacio
vectorial generado por dos vectores
linealmente independientes en el caso de
r2 es r 2 es decir el plano cartesiano
por lo tanto lo voy a poner aquí el
espacio vectorial generado por estos dos
vectores es r 2 y bueno todo esto
utilizando lo que acabamos de aprender
utilizando que si tenemos una
combinación lineal de dos vectores
igualdad a cero nos tenemos que aplicar
en las constantes para saber si es el
sistema independiente o dependiente así
que dejemos claro
por ejemplo y para esto voy a necesitar
un poco de espacio por lo tanto voy a
mover mi pantalla hasta acá arriba y
ahora la voy a mover un poco hacia la
derecha y ya quedó mucho mejor perfecto
voy a tomarme en esta ocasión un
conjunto de tres vectores mis tres
vectores van a ser los siguientes van a
ser el vector 2 1 también me voy a tomar
el vector 3 2 y también me voy a tomar
por último el vector 1 2 y bueno lo que
quiero saber es lo mismo si estos tres
vectores son linealmente dependientes o
independientes y bueno para esto lo que
voy a hacer es utilizar lo que ya vimos
lo que acabamos de ver es decir voy a
buscar una combinación lineal de esos
tres vectores que me den el vector cero
para fijarme en las correspondientes
constantes y ver si son todas cero o al
menos una es distinta de cero por lo
tanto déjame ponerlo c 1 que multiplica
el vector 2 1 + 2 que multiplica el
vector 3 2 + c 3 que multiplica el
vector 1 2 esto tiene que ser igual al
vector 0 0 date cuenta que seguimos con
vectores
nr 2 bueno esto es lo que se en un
primer paso en un segundo paso es
plantear el sistema de ecuaciones
correspondiente a esta igualdad por lo
tanto que me va a quedar tengo dos veces
ese 1 porque estoy multiplicando la
primera componente de mi primer vector
por la primer constante entonces me
quedaría dos veces 1 y después tengo que
multiplicar tres veces 2 porque estoy
multiplicando en la primera componente
del segundo vector por mi constante
entonces me queda tres veces 2 ya esto
le voy a agregarse 3 y va a ser igual a
la primera componente del tercero que es
0 y después voy a hacer lo mismo para la
segunda componente me quedan 1 más dos
veces dos más dos veces de tres esto
tiene que ser igual a la segunda
componente del vector 00 que es cero y
ahora tengo un sistema de dos ecuaciones
con tres incógnitas y bueno de una vez
te adelanto si yo tengo tres vectores en
r2 el sistema es siempre dependiente y
es que al final date cuenta de esto si
supongamos que todos estos vectores
generan el plano cartesiano entonces el
otro vector existe también en el plano
cartesiano pues es un vector también en
r2 y por lo tanto como existe
el plano cartesiano entonces se va a
poder escribir como una combinación
lineal de los otros vectores esto
suponiendo que dos de ellos sean
linealmente independientes porque si los
tres fueran linealmente dependientes
pues ya acabamos son linealmente
dependientes y formarían una línea recta
entonces si te das cuenta aquí tengo
tres vectores y ya la respuesta sería
que tenemos un conjunto con unos
vectores linealmente dependientes y van
a generar todo r2 así que déjame
escribirlos si tenemos tres vectores en
r dos son linealmente dependientes
verdad de todas maneras aunque tengo
aquí las dos ecuaciones con tres
incógnitas
voy a intentar resolverlo para que te
des cuenta que en efecto pasa lo
siguiente como tengo tres incógnitas voy
a aplicar a una de estas incógnitas y
voy a suponer que ese 3 le voy a dar el
valor de menos 1 voy a poner que ese 13
es igual a menos 1 para que yo tenga un
sistema de ecuaciones con solamente dos
incógnitas y dos ecuaciones por lo tanto
tenga solución entonces que me quedaría
si se 3 vale menos uno bueno date cuenta
que al sustituir hace 3 x menos 1 voy a
obtener un sistema de ecuaciones con dos
incógnitas
por lo tanto debe de tener solución y
ojo estoy tomando un valor para este 3
arbitrario puedo tomar cualquier valor
para este 3 pues este sistema tiene tres
incógnitas dos veces uno más tres veces
dos menos de tres pero ese 3 es menos 1
esto va a ser igual a 0 y por otro lado
tengo que ser uno más dos veces 2 y aquí
es dos veces de 3 es decir menos 2 es
igual a cero y bueno ya tengo un sistema
de ecuaciones con 25 venitas y dos
ecuaciones y por lo tanto voy a intentar
resolverlo me parece que a esta ecuación
a la ecuación número 2 le voy a
multiplicar por 2 entonces me queda dos
veces 14 veces c 2 y menos 4 igual a 0 y
voy a restar la primera ecuación a la
segunda ecuación que me va a quedar me
queda 12 1 - 12 1 se cancelan se van
después 13 2 - 4 0 2 nos quedarían menos
de 2 y después 1 - 1 - menos 4 me queda
3 positivo menos 14 me queda 3 positivo
y esto es igual a cero si estamos bien
ahora déjame llegar
3 - 4 - c 2
pues 1 - 4 me queda 14 lo cuales 3
positivo y bueno de aquí voy a despejar
hace 2 por lo tanto lo que voy a hacer
es pasar a voy a pasar el 3 del otro
lado iba a pasar con signo contrario me
queda que menos de 2 es igual al menos 3
de grant poniendo aquí menos de 2 va a
ser igual a menos 3 y como tengo dos
negativos los voy a convertir en
positivos al mismo tiempo y me queda que
ese 2 es igual a 3 y ya tengo hace 2
pues entonces lo único que me falta es
sacar hace 1 entonces qué va a pasar si
la segunda ecuación yo sustituyó hace
273 y entonces me va a quedar 2 por 13-6
menos 22 por menos 1 es menos 2 esto es
igual a cero y aquí obtengo que ese 14
es igual a cero y c1 es igual a menos 4
y ya tengo mis tres constantes c3 es
igual a menos uno de uno es igual a
menos cuatro se todos es igual a tres y
al menos una es distinta de cero por lo
tanto me está diciendo que existe más
dependiente y además cumple que si yo
multiplico sea uno por el primer rector
es decir menos cuatro por el primer
vector que es 21
c 2 que es 3 que multiplica el vector 3
2 ya esto le quito - una vez el vector
12 tiene que ser igual al vector 0 0 y
vamos a comprobar que sí es cierto menos
4 por 2 es 8 menos 8 + 9 menos uno menos
8 más 9 menos 1 eso sí es 0 y después es
menos 4 a menos 4 le voy a sumar 6 y
después le voy a quitar 2 y me queda
también 0 esto también es correcto
entonces se nota claramente que si en
efecto estas constantes hacen que
obtenga una combinación lineal con esos
tres vectores que sea igual al vector 0
y estas tres constantes son distintas de
0 por lo tanto me está diciendo que mi
sistema es de vectores linealmente
dependientes y bueno esto ya lo sabíamos
aunque dejamos escribirlo esto estoy
diciendo que el conjunto de vectores que
tengo aquí son vectores linealmente
dependientes y bueno esto es redundante
ya lo sabíamos pues sabíamos que este
conjunto tiene tres vectores y por lo
tanto debe de existir alguno que sea
linealmente dependiente de los otros dos
pero escoger el que realmente es
finalmente dependiente de los otros dos
no es tan fácil
no hay una manzana podrida en el montón
todas son iguales podría ser este oeste
al final podría pasarte cualesquiera dos
que tomemos sean linealmente
independientes pero bueno espero que le
des encontrado bastante utilidad a esto
que acabamos de ver porque en el
siguiente vídeo voy a ver más ejemplos
de esto así como del espacio vectorial
que generan varios vectores